الى السودان حيث افاد مراسل الجزيره بان
طائرات الحربيه لم تغب عن اجواء العاصمه
السودانيه الخرطوم منذ الصباح الباكر
اليوم ويترافق تحليق الطائرات الحربيه
معدوي اطلاق المدافع غربا ووسط الخرطوم
وجنوب ام درمان وكانت محاور القتال بين
الجيش السوداني وقوات الدعم السريع في
العاصمه شهدت معارك وصفت بانها من من
الاعنف في منذ اندلاع القتال بين الطرفين
وتركزات الاشتباكات حول منطقه اليرموك
للصناعات الدفاعيه جنوب الخرطوم ومواقع
وسط وجنوب مدينه ام درمان او في غرب
السودان قال البخاري احمد عبد الله نائب
رئيس التحالف السوداني الذي يحكم ولايه
غرب دارفور ان عدد القتلى خلال الاسابيع
الماضيه في مدينه الجنينه بلغ
850 اضافه الى الفي جريح وحرق مئات من
المنازل والاسواق فكشف بخاري انما سماها
الميليشيات دمرت كل الموارد ونهبت السوق
وجففت موارد المياه مع انقطاع لشبكه
الاتصالات
الميدانيه خاصه في الخرطوم معنى من هناك
اسامه سيد احمد اسامه
اعمده الدخان لازالت تتصاعد ورائك
واشتباكات وتحليق للطيران قربنا اكثر
نعمل كان منذ صباح الباكر كان هناك تحليق
مكثف للطيران الحربي تابعه للجيش السوداني
في سماء واسعه من ولايه الخرطوم طبعا تبعا
لذلك هناك اطلاق للمضادات الارضيه التابعه
لقوات الدعم السريع نستمع الى بعض الطلقات
الخفيفه في بعض المواطئ في بعض المواقع في
منطقه جنوب وجنوب شرق الخرطوم وبعض
المدافع الثقيله المتفرقه وليست منتظمه
طبعا الدخان الذي تشاهدونه خلفي هو ما
تبقى من الحريق الضخم الذي طال المستودعات
الرئيسيه لمخزون لمخزون الغاز والوقود
الجنوب الخرطوم هذه المنطقه منطقه الدخان
الكثيف الذي تشاهدونه الان محيط هذا
المكان شهيد اشتباكات عنيفه امس هي تعتبر
هي الاعنف من نوعها منذ الدلاع الحرب في
الخامس عشر من ابريل الماضي ما بين الجيش
السوداني وقوات الدعم السريع هذه المنطقه
كذلك مجابر لها كذلك دارت اشتباكات عنيفه
في محيط مجمع اليرموك وهو احدى المؤسسات
العسكريه المهمه التابعه لمنظومه الصناعات
الدفاعيه التابع للجيش السوداني بعد هذه
المعارك التي اندلعت في محيط هذا المكان
خرج بيان من قوات الدعم السريع اشار الى
انه استطاع السيطره الكامله على هذا
الموقع موقع مجمع اليرموك ولكن لم يكن
هناك بيان رسمي من الجيش السوداني ينفي ما
اشار اليه له بيان قوات الدعم السريع سوى
بعض المصادر العسكريه التابعه للجيشه
السوداني التي تحدثت وقالت انها ان الجيش
السوداني استطاعه صب هجوم على هذا موقع
اذن يعني بعدد من المواقع ايضا المحيطه
بهذا المكان سواء كان في منطقه جبرا وشارع
الهوى وكذلك بعض الاماكن القريبه من هذا
المكان شاهد اشتباكات عنيفه هي كما ذكرنا
هي الاعنف من نوعها منذ اندلاع الحرب في
الخامس عشر من ابريل الماضي الان
الخرطوم تشهد هدوءا حذرا سوى بعض يعني
نستمع الى بعض الطلقات الخفيفه من اسلحه
خفيفه وبعض
القنابل الصوتيه القنابل هنا وهناك ولكن
طبعا تستمر هذه الحرب وسط امنيات
للمواطنين السودانيين الذين خرجوا مضطرين
من منازلهم
لوقف دائم لاطلاق النار حتى ان يتمكنوا من
العوده الى بلادهم الى الخرطوم والى
منازله من جديد
شكرا لك من الخرطوم من شرق الخرطوم تحديدا
اسامه السيد احمد وايضا